is for new businesses to set up shop are
in high demand right now the commercial
and industrial real estate market up 25
since right before the pandemic started
and less than two percent of available
buildings are empty as joe mohler
reports some attributed to the growing
local economy
[Music]
for a while now we have showed you how
well the las vegas housing market has
been doing especially throughout the
pandemic but as las vegas economy grows
more businesses are taking an interest
in commercial and industrial spaces the
growing las vegas economy is attracting
businesses and they are looking for
office space uncommons in the southwest
valley is prime example the new mixed
office and retail area is not even open
yet and the first phase of office space
is already leased i spoke to tom van
betten about the demand here he says
many companies are looking for unique
spaces with more to offer he says
draftkings is putting their north
american headquarters here we are
starting to see companies from
california industrial they've been
coming from california for a long time
but on office we now start to get a lot
of inquiries uh about companies to even
tech companies thinking about moving
from the barrier area to las vegas
and and asking us about our space
industrial buildings are also doing well
brian kruger from coldwell banker shed
some light on the industrial sector he
says vacancy rates are low and more
buildings are being built for later this
year but many of those projects are
pre-released back here at uncommons van
betten says the second phase which is
now under construction is about 20
percent pre-leased the first tenants
will move into the first phase later
this month reporting in the southwest
valley joe muller live local now
joe thank you for that well experts also
say labor shortages remain an obstacle
for future developments although lumber
prices may help margins slightly but
time is a major issue in development